I'm gonna feel the size of that Bobo
ball in my mouth people know me as like
the crazy Bobo girl so I was gifted this
beautiful suck my balls Bobo shirt I
love boba but I don't love boba if that
makes what people say like oh I have to
go for my daily Starbucks friend I'm
like no I need my daily boba run right
I'm not someone who's super super into
chewing my drinks but maybe my mind will
change today
I love boba my go-to flavor though is a
classic I like the milky boba I really
love the fresh taste of it mixed with
the sweetness the milkiness if you get
the right consistency of balls then it's
delicious bring on the first boba the
classic milk tea just truth
[Music]
I feel like the flavors go together
it's just a little bit more on the sweet
side you can taste the tea the balls
they're like a big gloopy on the outside
right like they're not super firm the
insides a little bit firm but on the
outside it's kind of goofy or maybe then
I would usually really enjoy I would say
this is pretty good it kind of tastes
like home a little bit oh right I love
the creaminess with with the milk in
there I just got a nice rounded flavor
to it they're really got slimy with the
outside if I was really craving boba and
this is by my house I would probably
stop by but okay cool but with time I
mean okay already looking at it does it
look a little bit harder no they look so
the tea actually tastes a little bit
chocolaty and creamy this is definitely
more of like a creamy kind of milky or
tea for sure tastes a little like honey
maybe it's sweeter than the other one is
well sweeter than the other one in not a
good way I will agree with you in the
sense that the boba does have a nice
texture but the tea is so off the boba
is also much smaller though this flaw
it's more subtle I think a little less
chewy too what happens is that I get
stuck in the straw when you have to let
you suck hard and then it all comes out
right now this is boba tea that would
get divorced she's fancy like okay she's
also really much lighter this will be
the most milky I'm assuming so Gong cha
is what I know is like the best chain to
be drinking from in Los Angeles right
now
of the three so far this is definitely
the strongest good quality tea leaves
good quality milk great boba happy girl
it's such a subtle tea flavor how do you
feel about the bobo this bulb is much
more chewy I think they're not too big
and they have that chewiness almost like
an out dente sort of pasta situation you
know let's get it on let's do it I taste
the team this is definitely much aroma
no no maybe I was wrong I think that
this is another time
well the Thai I'm going to say that this
is mr. boma
you're wrong sorry my friend I'm gonna
feel the size of that bolo ball in my
mouth I'm pretty sure I know this is by
the time I think you might be right but
I'm gonna go with mr. lovely this is
bull vataj I think this one is bullying
they can't be gone chef that would be
crazy
I think how that this tea doesn't have
that chocolaty taste that you were
talking about earlier about Bova times
so this one has to be mr. Bobo these
ruins are bigger okay I'm gonna say so
mr. Bobo take it back I hear the other
ones go with them okay
has mr. know about mr. Bullock I think
so just because the boba I remember the
bull would be in Colombia I'm gonna go
with mr. Bober
this is boa time first one we had was
mr. bull I base it on the ball I'm gonna
guess that this is the girl child come
tap yeah I'm gonna go a going charm a
little blow job I'm gonna second that
yeah I think so
wow this is gone too it's definitely
I thought I knew what I was talking
about it's a holistic experience because
I really do pay attention to the Bobo
ball
oh did I do it
I feel so validated all I'd like to
thank my mom maybe I should have
switched my my game plan here and gone
more of the boba route than the T route
if that's just because what I know is T
it's so interesting to see how how much
harder is to tell the difference as soon
as you're only relying on your sense of
taste I would say it takes a few times
to get used to eating the tapioca ball a
lot of people don't like it first time
they try it but I would say really girls
on people
[Music]
[Music]